[Music]
in the summer of 2007
i was promoting a movie called die hard
four live free or die hard it was called
and as part of the promotional tour we
got to go all around the world it was so
cool and
i was allowed to bring one person and i
decided to bring my friend john togo i
guess i was unavailable yeah sorry i
don't know why i didn't bring you
i don't know
if i ever do a another big movie at one
point we stopped in berlin and up until
that point bruce willis had been around
john a lot and
he thought he was my assistant he just
didn't know that john was also an actor
and so when we were in berlin
uh togo went out for a jog
and i guess bruce was outside signing
some autographs or there were autograph
seekers outside and as
togo left the hotel
like half the autograph seekers turned
and spotted him and started pursuing him
so they were like chasing john down the
street
later that day bruce came up to me and
he said
hey uh
what does john do he
he must have thought that he was like
the best assistant ever yeah
he was like famous for being an amazing
assistant and the germans would value
that i guess
really on top of things that's really
responsible
life could be a dream
you're listening to life for short i'm
your host justin long life could be a
dream
and with me as always is christian long
hello
uh christian was not there i you know
hello again oh yeah christian was not
thank god with me as always is my
brother hello oh i thought you wanted to
try that again i thought you wanted to
try a better one i did oh that was
better yeah okay
um
yeah it was so such a fun trip and it
was such a funny moment that
togo realized that he had and later
later that night we all hung out there
was a premiere in berlin and we had an
after party was really fun and bruce
started treating him like a person
yeah he started he was just different
around him i don't know what to say um
yeah i think you do notice yeah i don't
want to say it but um
why are we talking about togo togo uh a
shorty himself he is a shorty yeah big
fan of the show he's been so supportive
and um and uh he often critiques the
show uh and he's my best friend so i
it's a welcome critique
uh and he
yeah he's a big big uh
speaking of john togo oh right uh a
friend of john togo
is our guest on the show today our
friend uh dear dear friend maggie q
uh maggie quigley known to everyone else
is maggie q
uh maggie is
an ex-girlfriend of yours of mine yeah
not just of
and of other people yes yes she's had
other exes yeah other lovers she's taken
um
and maggie is just one of my favorite
people she's so you met her doing die
hard that's you hadn't met her before
and she you were both cast in this movie
and i had seen her in mission impossible
three she often plays um
ass kicking yeah that term that we're
not crazy about badasses badasses she's
a badass it definitely applies to maggie
um i think that term gets i don't it's
not that i don't like the term i think
it just gets overused agreed but she is
such a badass and
in die hard she was playing that role a
villain role timothy olyphant was the
main villain and
she was maggie was like her henchmen
right yeah yeah woman henchwomen and
we'll talk about this so i don't want to
repeat myself but we just i just had so
much fun we had so much fun together on
that and then and then your friendship
and love blossomed yes it did and uh and
it remains she remains when a romantic
relationship didn't remain but yeah
friendship did remain yeah and you've
been close friends for
many years now yeah i just so admire her
and whenever maggie and i hang out we
you know it'll turn into hours and um so
we'll cut it down a little bit yeah so
in addition to uh mission impossible
three and die hard she's also known for
being
the lead in the series nikita that was
on for a few years and it was on
designated survivor far more important
than that stuff and she's wonderful
she's very talented uh maggie is one of
the most compassionate people i know and
she's become a
a very
very brave very courageous activist uh
on behalf of both the environment and
animals animal rights and she got me
involved in
certain organizations that i
brought enriched my life and we'll talk
about that in the interview uh and how
she came to
have this love this real deep love for
animals
so we're gonna get into that and so much
more uh with the
wonderful just hilarious kind
compassionate friend oh the animals
and humans and humans yes friend of
humans sorry
maggie q
life could be a dream sweetheart
hello hello
[Music]
i'm outside in the yard oh
oh yeah it's time i see here little
birds
oh can you hear that yeah i've got some
gorgeous um i've got a bird bath
and you know i feed them so they all
come
sure wait max do you
do you do people know is your last name
a well-known thing i was wondering and
and
is that something that you mean
well i was when i was on leno
once
which as you know
jl
um
you know i mean he wasn't he's not did
you say it wasn't the most fun show
not the easiest it's not the easiest
yeah like there are certain talk show
hosts that are like a pleasure to do and
there are other ones that are like it's
like pulling teeth did he ever come
backstage with you and just kind of like
chit chat he did and i'll tell you he
was so nice to my family
and um you know you know my mom
my mom has no idea who jay leno is and
she
wait wait
how would you describe your mom in just
a in a nutshell
you know my mother is a vietnamese
immigrant she's an incredible woman
she's worked really hard she's very um
you know i once said oh your buttons
match your shoes that's cool and she
looked at me and she went
mama know what's up
so he was so kind he came back you know
he heard my mom and sister were there or
whatever right so he he really was kind
it's just that his show like he's very
scripted as you know and so if you go
off screen with jay leno it's harder
right
yes he uh well just really quick i i
found that when he came backstage he was
very easy to talk to uh same like very
kind to my family and like super kind
talk to all of us and really like kind
of
easy and connected and then and then and
weirdly his his voice and then you go on
stage and his voice shot up and i was
like you know he's dead you're doing it
um but totally lovely and and whatever
sorry so continue so you're backstage so
so lovely yeah and it's weird that it's
like it's show time and like people
climb up i mean normally it's the
opposite right i mean i it's show time
and people are amazing and then they
come off stage and like you don't know
how to speak to them so he comes back
and he says hi to my sister and you know
my mom has no idea what's going on right
and then
and then i said and then mom goes so i
said mom this is jay and he goes hi you
know miss miss q it's so nice to meet
you blah blah blah
that's my sister
and he has his back turned to me and my
mom because he's saying something to my
sister
and my mom turns me to honey who it did
man
and i said
that's
[Laughter]
i said mom that that's the man that's
that's the guy this is his show and she
honey did his show how hit show did his
show honey he is so nice to you
and i said well
yeah like i'm a guest tonight like
i'm like i'm like honestly
she didn't understand why she didn't
understand like why he would want me
because my mom's asians are nothing i
mean nothing we do is good enough so she
couldn't well well well wait a minute
well i want to get into that
wait but but the stuff that you did in
asia because you had a huge career
before you had a huge career in america
in asia so that stuff must have been
cool to her oh no i don't
i don't quite know that it was to be
honest like you know it's sort of like
really certain people will gauge like
it's it's it's cool to them that people
know who you are but i don't know if
they really i don't know if she maybe
now she does but at the time i don't
think she really grasped that they knew
who i am because of my work
or because like
i do hopefully some quality things that
people
like i've noticed well my parents do
anyway uh which we'll get to
um they i think they watched every
episode of nikita did you know that
they were like faithful nikita no i know
they watched designated survivor which
seems about right
oh they watch all your stuff they watch
your stuff more than my stuff
well
they my dad yeah that's true okay for
example like after we did die hard uh
the new york times did this like whole
page on like
and by the way i don't know why they did
it but they just this whole page on my
career and how weird it was and they
were like you know here's this american
chick who lived and worked in asia first
and made this name for herself and then
she crosses back over to the us but so
my sister said
mom did you see that page of maggie in
the new york times and i don't tell my
family anything that comes out like
nothing like they'll be like you know
they'll go to work and be like oh i saw
your daughter on letterman last night
they're like what like they you know i
never
tell anybody because i don't care just
let them in and my mom
looked at her and said so there's this
little free newspaper like in our town
it's called the continent
in hawaii yeah in hawaii in this little
town where we live and it's free and
it's it's small you know it's like legal
sized
so my sister says this to her and she
sort of looks at my sister kind of
bewildered and says
well they don't write about her in the
canoe peppa
because that's her local newspaper right
like that's what she picks up
that has value and the new york times
doesn't have any value for her because
she doesn't really think that you're so
interesting right right well it's all
yeah it's all depends on your
perspective and and
i'm sure
and i can attest to this personally
you're a massive star in asia like i've
been to chinatown with you
i can i just trust me everyone
like you can't
she doesn't pass an asian person who's
not like ah
what the [ __ ]
first of all and i know a lot of this so
we're going to retread a few things but
i also want to
it's it's nice for me to update uh in
terms of my friendship with you it's
good to just i have a terrible memory so
some of this i actually don't remember
yeah yeah um
so you moved to tokyo to pursue
modeling why
well here's what's interesting
you
what made you think uh
did you
so how old were you then when you moved
from honolulu i graduated from high
school i was 17 years old
in hawaii and i had a girlfriend uh
called mary
who
[Music]
was it's the same mix as me she's happy
to meet half white she's so beautiful
and she's always been sort of this
darling and all these clients would come
to hawaii and they'd shoot catalogs and
she was always their star on the cover
of their magazines and stuff and she was
really beautiful and very successful
and mary had it on lock she would go
you know to asia every summer and model
and make a bunch of money and come home
and i was like wow like
i mean i wanted to be her when i grew up
and so she was just like mags you know
like you need to just come with me and
i'll help you and by the way just so
we're clear models don't do this
you know people who are legitimately
working and have success aren't like hey
you who looks you know not dissimilar to
me i mean i was yeah right right for
competition
right like they don't go like hey you
know
come on come on over to tokyo with me
i'll introduce you to my clients and
help you out like that just doesn't
happen so but she liked you i mean it
was just it's as simple as that like
she's she did and she was like slightly
older than me so i think she took a a
like an older sister position yeah and i
really did i think she thought that i
quite rightly that i was um really
having a hard time i was really
struggling with paying for school and
seeing you know seeing the future and
what it could what it could be and my
whole situation so
max what did you see like at that point
what was the what did the future look
like all i knew which you know well
because you know me well as i loved
animals more than i could even you know
express
they were always my my joy and i wanted
to work with animals and one of the
things i said to myself when i was
younger was
i want to help animals that's what i
want to do in my life and i thought at
the time to do that i wanted to be that
so because i thought that was the only
way you helped animals is if it's to be
a vet you know you help them medically
and
the nice thing about what i've been able
to do and parlay my career into as an
activist and as you know someone who's
worked in uh animal nonprofit for over
20 years now um i've been able to
fulfill that dream weirdly um in a very
different way and had to become a vet i
would never help as many animals as i do
now exactly in such an impactful way but
you where did that come from i don't
think i do know this like what do you
remember a formative moment like a
memory that stands out that was like
i'm picturing you seeing like a crippled
deer on the side of the road and nursing
it back to health or something we don't
have deer in hawaii but yeah oh okay
[Laughter]
there's nothing dangerous there's no
snakes there's no yeah a crippled snake
okay you know i mean
i know your podcast is super fun and i'm
not going to bring anyone down but i
will say no you don't want to see
yeah in all honesty you know i
people people were very nice to me
uh humans and yes
um and and people were very hurtful and
yeah when i was down when i was hurt
when i when i had no words for for
people or i couldn't turn to anyone
that that love that unconditional
non-judgmental
um
warmth and dedication
to another person no matter what you
look like no matter how you're acting no
matter who likes you or doesn't whether
you have friends you're popular you're
not like there's no
there's no st animals don't have that
type of standard right because they're
not shallow like we are right there
they're not
to have those type of prejudices right
they live purely on instinct and and
they're they're the most they're the
purest expressions of love that i've
ever been around to be honest and that's
not to say i mean you hear a lot of
animal people say you know i like
animals more than people i love no i
love people i love both i i think people
are incredible and i also think that
i can't help animals unless i like
people and if you're excluding people
you're not going to get anywhere yeah
yeah well so matt so okay let's go back
to your your 17 18 you're out of high
school you're having trouble paying
bills your friend mary then says hey
uh this is this modeling might be
something you you want to look into
then do you just go how do you how do
you go from that to you meet her agent
well
you know there's there's these sort of
contracts that happen in in the modeling
world and i'm not talking like at the
top level you know there's sort of like
indentured servitude contracts that
happen
oh wow yeah they pay your way to the
country
of choice whichever one it is that
you're going to and then they charge you
exorbitant amounts of money for
all kinds of things to get photos done
for your rent i mean they're really
they're really like sticking it to these
girls because you're too young you don't
know what the deal is right yeah i'm so
glad i avoided all those people who
wanted me to do that you were just smart
you were just smarter than the rest of
us oh yeah
yeah and finally you know frankly i was
yeah
it was tempting it was tempting but i
i thought no i'm on a different path
how much of this do you know going into
it or are you learning the hard way then
yeah definitely learning the hard way
they're deducting your rent they're
deducting all these things and you know
they they take the risk and they make
sure that you're gonna try to get at
least a job so you can pay them back so
that they're covered but really it's
just this awful reputation
it's a horrible industry i mean it's
disgusting i mean there was a a white
board up right when you walked in the
agency and had every girl that you know
was working at the time
name listed
and then um every friday when you'd come
into the agency to check in they'd weigh
you and then they put your weight up on
the board so everybody could see it oh
my god
and your weight from the previous weeks
was also there so you could see if
people gained weight
wow what they did as well one of the
things that it served um uh was
the way that they would pit girls
against each other so girls would come
in and be like oh so-and-so so skinny
and i'm not or i gained weight and she
didn't know god and so that's how they
would create a competition so that girls
would starve themselves and not ever
gain any weight yeah and these are
teenagers so already they have yeah
already these teenagers probably have
such
yeah insecurities and oh my god i was
always the one who was who never gained
a pound and it was because i was so
poor
that i couldn't afford food i mean i
literally
if i had
and at this time and this is in the late
90s you know you know how expensive
japan is
uh there were like four apples in a
package and by the end of the week if i
could save up like 10 bucks u.s at the
time i could buy those apples and i was
so excited because
i couldn't afford fruit i couldn't
afford anything and so it was sort of
like
you know i i literally didn't have
enough money to eat proper meals and so
i was just like buying little things
from 7-eleven and eating them when i
could afford them oh the other models
must have been like [ __ ] her pretty much
like it was always the brazilian the
pretty brazilian girls that i had a good
time with because we kind of had the
same
i was an island girl and they were a
little like you know we're warm weather
girls
now this is something i forget did you
harbor desires at that point to be an
actress or is it something you had done
in school never never yeah wow well i
was a creative person but i don't come
from a creative family and so
maybe if you grew up now that would be
fine and parents would look at you and
recognize your individualism and go how
amazing you're not like us but hey you
should really
do pottery and you should write poetry
you should do all the things that i did
as a kid how did you get from tokyo to
hong kong because hong kong there was a
thriving
uh movie
business there uh there was an agency
interested in me in taiwan and so i flew
to taipei and i was um i don't think
i've ever been more depressed in my life
i was poor and it was cold and i again
like i didn't japanese culture i was
very familiar with because i was born
and raised in hawaii and so i mean
japanese culture is just like it's the
most dominant culture in hawaii like
everyone's japanese or mixed with
japanese
and then i went to taiwan and this was a
totally foreign culture language people
like the whole thing was so
and then i was just trying to make a
little bit more money and i didn't know
anyone and i didn't you know i i just it
was so i was so lost and so scared and
as luck would have it when i was there
at the time they were looking for like
caucasian blonde girls with blue eyes or
famous chinese people those were the
people getting jobs and i would walk in
the room and they yeah they didn't want
anything that was exotic looking they
didn't like that it was not the vibe of
the time so i got rejected from every
single job that i was up for and i was
like oh god i don't know what i'm going
to do and so
so you're in a market lonely lonely poor
i would walk to the market spend my
dollar and then i would spend like an
extra 25 cents on an ear of corn like a
cooked corn
and it made me happy and i remember
going back to this shitty love motel i
was living in and there was a guy who
worked at the front desk
this guy would watch me and so he
finally asked me one day he said how
much did you pay for that corn i said
like 25 cents and he goes that's really
expensive they're ripping you off
because you're a foreigner and i said oh
well i really like corn and it makes me
happy and he's like don't buy it anymore
they're ripping you off
and i was like uh okay so the next night
i go to the market i come back
he was working there and
i think he saw how sad i was and how
alone i was and so that night i walk in
without the corn and he looks more
excited than he's ever seen in the month
i had been living there
and he's waving for me to come over and
i'm like christ what is happening
she takes me to this back room
i'm standing there and i i really i
truly thought oh my god there's gonna be
like body parts and he opens the bag and
it's full of corn
just like ears and ears of corn and he
says
and he says to me you know
every night when you come home i'll boil
you one and then and then you don't have
to pay
so much money because i bought this
whole bag for the price that you paid
for that one corn i just looked at him
and then i went up to my room and i just
cried and cried and cried because at
that point
not a lot of people had been nice to me
and so
that simple thing and that's why being
kind to people so important because
but genuinely kind i mean not so people
will like you i mean genuinely seeing
something in someone that
you know a void or something that's
missing and showing them kindness
because you have no clue where that
person's at you have no clue what that
will do to someone and and weirdly
enough he doesn't know this and because
of his kindness in that moment
when i was in the market that night i
met this woman who gave me her phone
number and she said
uh and it had written down another phone
number actually and said uh you know
what are you doing here and i said well
i'm not a model
so i don't work
and she said you should go to hong kong
and i was like i don't want to go to
another country where i don't know
anyone i don't speak a language i don't
know a soul like i just can't do it i'm
just too sad like i don't
she just said i think they'll get you in
hong kong i just think that it's it's a
very international city and i i think
you'll do very well there and i was like
what hong kong i never even i brought
hong kong had probably never crossed my
mind in my life
in the early 2000s millions of
households across the world tuned in to
watch contestants battle for the last
rose or to be the final survivor on the
island reality tv was beginning to
dominate the airwaves and every show
needed to be bigger flashier more
scandalous than the last but in the case
of one infamous dating show the real
drama was happening off-screen and it
would shape the future of reality tv the
reality tv series there's something
about miriam seemed like a pretty
standard dating competition six young
men vibed for the affection of miriam
rivera a beautiful model from mexico but
when miriam revealed that she was a
trans woman during the show's finale the
on-screen drama sparked an international
uproar about gender sexuality and
whether reality television had finally
gone too far follow harsh reality the
story of miriam rivera on apple podcast
amazon music or you can listen early and
add free by joining wondering plus in
apple podcasts or the wandery app
[Music]
hello hello
[Music]
so you're you're listening to this at
this point this woman people are just
drawn to you for whatever for whatever
reason and she's she's she's telling you
should go to hong kong
she writes down a phone number for me
she writes on a phone number for me and
uh i go back to the hotel i have the
corn incident in the lobby i go to my
room i'm bawling my eyes
and you know this this man will never
understand
you know because i'm sure to him he
thought it was such a small thing uh
saving someone money it's very asian you
know i'm sure he just oh yeah yeah i'll
save her some money and that'll help her
out but he doesn't really get
fundamentally how how that changed my
life because
right it was that one act of kindness
that sort of
gave me faith again that people can be
kind that that there are nice people on
the world and that i'm going to take my
chances
and try to find more of them
but he gave me the confidence and i
called a friend and i asked to western
union me uh enough money to buy a
one-way ticket to hong kong i had no
clue what i was doing
i flew to hong kong and i um called the
number
and it was a woman and she said well who
are you and i said i got your number
from this lady
and she said come to my office so i took
a bus with my luggage to her office
and she said uh you know are you you
know do you have any photos and i had
like two photos at that time like two
photos of myself yeah and she's like ugh
she does not know what to do she's just
like who is this girl and what am i
gonna do with her
and she said all right well do you have
enough money to rent a room at one of
the you know modeling apartments and i'm
like i really don't
so she took me in and i i slept on her
floor for a year until i could afford to
rent a room of my own
wow that's right i know wow yeah so she
really was
my angel do you then start going up for
movies that hong kong had a thriving
action
movie business right that was like a big
thing in hong kong was well yeah how
come the
the hollywood of asia or has been i mean
now china has taken over um but hong
kong you know has such a long history of
filmmaking especially the action genre
and you know so it really was one of
those places but you know i i did you
know justin i did like toothpaste and
bank commercials and you know things
like that oh okay it wasn't until
you know i modeled for like a year
uh and then after that
it was actually jackie chan at the time
he had a management company where he was
looking for like the new young actors
the next generation of action stars and
he was wanting to produce these movies
for a younger generation with with
younger stars in them
and he was kind of looking for his his
core group of and they were obviously
asia so you know they they value the
boys way more than they ever valued me
but
um
they were looking yeah they were looking
for the new the next uh wave of young
stars and they chose all these guys and
then they chose i was i was one of the
girls i think there was another girl who
did like a movie with them but i don't
think she went on to do anything else
max how did you get chosen for that like
is it an audition process is it a
meeting objective so it started to see
me like in the papers and on television
and they just were sort of like yes this
girl and i thought why are they coming
and so when they came knocking and said
hey she's brushing her teeth so much
so well
and uh
they
they uh they basically uh said you know
we want to sign you and i said no oh wow
why because
i was really bad at it i was really bad
at it and i remember i didn't feel
comfortable
no no i was i was i hated it really i
had no confidence i mean i had zero well
i mean there's nowhere i would have
gotten it from and then
you know with asians when they think
something about you they just tell you
they don't try to placate the situation
they don't try to pump you up they're
just like you suck
and you shouldn't be here and you're
like oh okay wow
so at that point when you're you're now
jackie chan who were you like holy [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] is happening were you
excited some people say like oh well
somebody that big and famous offered you
something you don't take it like how
stupid oh i thought the opposite i
thought if somebody that big and famous
is offering you something and you and
you take it and you can't do it you're
really never ever going to recover from
that right no you have the expectations
the pressure from that right and by the
way my instincts were completely correct
because i ended up working with him for
seven years
and uh his expectations are incredibly
high
you not feel like you
reached those expectations you like i
don't think anyone around him feels that
they reach those expectations oh oh wow
i think that's sort of the syndrome you
know it's sort of you wanted to be proud
of you
yeah but he
he is the kind of man who has worked his
ass off
to get what he has and he has been
through
so much hardship
in his life and
he really earned every second of his
fame and his notoriety and his wealth he
he really has i don't know anyone who
works he's driven he's really driven
like tom cruise works as like those are
the two hardest working men i've never
seen two men that work harder and so you
sort of look at the result of their life
and career
you know as a result of how hard they
work and you go well yeah i get it i get
why you have what you have and i think
you have you did it um so with jackie
chan because you're working with this
like really driven person do you
yourself ever feel
like you've
reached a point where he's impressed and
you feel fulfilled what were those seven
years like i don't think i've ever asked
you this um no because there is no
you can't
you can't impress or fulfill someone
who's not fulfilled or impressed with
themselves
right right
so he he is so driven and such a hard
worker that
he never feels for himself i mean
someone who has his enormous amount of
wealth fame and notoriety i mean there's
no one like him right i would argue that
he's one of the most unique
uh entertainers out there um yeah and
and yet he's not satisfied with what
he's done he's always he's always
fighting to to be more and give more and
do more and
a person like that
really doesn't look at other people
and say oh that's really great i mean
they they just don't they can't
um so no that never happened it wasn't
like hey great job no
no
well then when
are you enjoying is there a part of you
that do you feel like you're getting
better at what you're doing are you you
must be doing a lot of martial arts
training well i do i do and like he
jackie has a team of like 10 to 12
whatever stunt guys who are experts in
all disciplines and if you if you know
jackie's movies and
and you know his team you can see that
he's always fighting the same people in
his movies because you can't just fight
with jackie chan you have to fight at a
certain level so
no matter who the actor is or whatever
the situation is it's always his guys
he's fighting yeah it's like the harlem
globetrotters always playing the same
team
exactly
you have to because your skill sets are
not matched by means jackie chan but you
know what i'm saying like they know what
he wants yeah he knows what they need
and they're able to give us a
performance that's just like
mind-blowing like not anything you've
ever seen did you ever get did you ever
get hurt like training with them
uh yeah i mean i i like tore my inner
thigh and like things were just like i
just went too far but you know no broken
bones or anything which is very very
strange but um because i could have
easily gotten so hurt for so
many reasons but
because you make up something could you
just make up one just for the podcast
just to make it sound oh
well i did i actually cracked my [ __ ]
there was a stunt with this this oh
that'll work okay yeah this coordinator
this guy ching tsudong was he's like a
really really famous like old school
coordinator and he directed this movie
that i did with him and and he was like
you know we'll just put you on top of a
ladder and then when he kicks you the
wire will just like
like you know ratchet you back and i'm
like on a ladder that seems really
unstable
and he goes yeah but you know you're
hooked up to the wires it doesn't matter
and i'm like what that [ __ ] i still
don't
so but the guy flying at me who's doing
like the flying kick was supposed to
like hit me in the stomach and i had a
pad on my stomach i mean it still hurts
but like you have a pad at least so his
shoe is not like cutting your stomach
open but he um
there was no real it was so not precise
and so what happened was he ended up
like launching himself off one ladder
and i'm like on another ladder
and it was this dangerous and he um he
ended up falling short so what he did
was instead of like getting me in the
torso where i was petted he kicked me
like a did a flying kick to my shin oh
god
i know it was really i thought i was
gonna die and so of course i fell off
the ladder
oh my god wait max
are there not as many like regulations
do they not have the same safety
measures there's no regulation no none
oh okay there's no safety officer
no there's none of that
none of that especially back then are
you on are you opening a box
are you talking to me yeah oh i opened
your keys sorry guys that's funny that
that box of cookies sounded like um it
sounded like you're opening some big
package
so when you do stunts like this you
can't it's not like you can say in
america you can say to the coordinator
um is this say i mean they they don't
let actors in america
do stunts basically
yeah i mean
like a certain level yeah at a certain
level like unless you're tom cruise you
can't you can't tell him not to do
something if he wants to do it right
right um right yeah but but for the most
part when people when actors are like i
did all my own stunts it's like no you
didn't like these incredibly precise
trains stunned people did the dangerous
ones but there
and this is where you cut your teeth and
your chin um
you had to do your own stuff and and you
didn't have
i did and
and here's where i kind of made my mark
i
on this one particular movie weird the
same movie we were talking about i had
four different stunt women
and wow
they were all fired
oh my god and
because i was better than they were
oh my god crazy
wow i i do stunts and not get injured
and like the stunt girls would get
injured and they would just screw this
enormous hierarchy in asia where
you know the coordinator like is the be
all and all and this in this case the
coordinator was the director as well and
he's very famous very well known and
there's
there's a reverence that comes with that
in asia especially there's a lot of
respect for people who have experience
and years on you and so all of the
stuntmen and all of his helpers they're
all scared of him so
wow if he says you gotta do something or
something's gonna be done
people just do it there's no like oh is
it safe like oh my god so that's the
school i come from right and so wow i
get back to the states i get mission
impossible it's my first movie in the
u.s and i'm doing my fights and doing my
stuff and i'm getting all these
compliments like all these americans you
know americans overdo it anyway right
americans say [ __ ] they don't mean right
oh my god you look amazing oh
they'll support you and they'll try to
make it better for you but like asians
won't do that right so they kiss your
ass more yeah they can ask more they do
and there's a little bit i mean
sometimes it's nice and sometimes it's
fake like whatever like anywhere i guess
but i got back and i'm doing this movie
and everyone's like
you're so amazing you're so this and
you're all these so i'm getting all
these compliments and and you never got
there no hot no
i don't know how to react i don't know
what to say it makes me feel weird like
no one's ever told me i've done a good
job no one's ever it was so strange it
was like having like an abusive parent
right and then going to like your aunt's
house who's like really nice and buys
her kids whatever they want
right you know and you're like can i
have a drink and she gives you a menu of
juices and sodas you can have and you're
like what what she's like
yeah
she passes you the soda you cower
yeah
yeah
just leave it there over my own uh well
yeah you know it's funny i cause you're
crying
uh yeah yeah i noticed uh i worked with
um several japanese actors
last year shout out to takahiro hira and
yosuka uh
they're such great guys and and so i'm
talking about professional they were
never complained always oh yeah just the
best
but they told me tak said um he in fact
is moving to hawaii or maybe he already
has because um the system there
in japan is so different than it is here
the most striking thing is that the
agents
some agents take like 50
of uh in commissions it's between like
some more wow oh my god
oh my god it's like that in hong kong as
well like 50 between 50 and 70 some of
them oh my god and they tell you they
um yeah and that to me there's no
autonomy there's very little autonomy
yeah there's a lot of bullying that goes
on too you know it's sort of like if you
don't do this we're not going to give
you this or you're not going to get that
or
you know people are going to
you know you'll you'll never work again
in this way
by the way
you came over after
people might not know this you were in
hong kong for like how how many years
eight nine years seven years seven years
seven seven years
and so what brought you
was it tom cruise was did somebody see
movies that because you had been doing a
bunch of movies yeah no it was jj abrams
it was jj
was told about me and apparently he had
he had you know jj is very specific with
his casting and he
i guess had read a bunch of girls for
mission possible and just was like no i
found her yet where did he see he saw a
movie you were in i'm actually not
totally clear what he saw but i i got
into the room
april webster you know april right from
paramount you know she's amazing casting
director she's just she's so one of the
top just but also just like such a good
human she
i think maybe had presented me she saw
something i did i don't know what it was
and he said yes i want to see her so i
fly in from hong kong and you know the
jet lag when you fly from asia to
l.a the jet lag hits you about 3 00 p.m
you're done
and so
i flew in that night i was so sick i
don't know what happened i got the flu
something
i woke up the next day and i thought i
was dying and i called april and i was
like oh my god like my fever was so high
i was delirious it was like 105.
holy [ __ ] and i didn't know what to do i
know and she said come down to the
studio let's let's let's let's talk and
work you through this
and i said what time is my audition and
she's like three o'clock of course like
right right at the time when like jet
lag hits you and you want to die
and i was on top of that i was sick so i
went down to paramount and she's like
this is your movie like i know this is
your movie you
you're her and i'm like oh okay
and so she kind of like took care of me
until three o'clock like
got fluids in me like i mean she did
what she could i was obviously very very
ill so i go and i had to read three
scenes for jj and
i read the three scenes for him and
i was so i went from being so cold they
had to put a blanket over me because i
was shaking and my teeth were chattering
to sweating so profusely that like i
like i had was wiping my br my forehead
with my whole arm
and so you know the stage is a fever
right
and
so i did the three scenes and
i had nothing left i didn't know i did
the scenes i just sat there and he
looked at me and jj said i will do
anything to have you in this movie oh my
god and he said
let's do this like my reaction to to
being offered one of the biggest movies
of all time
was
i think i need to go to the hospital
oh she's so excited she's going to faint
she's got to go
so
i was in the hospital and i think it was
like a kidney infection it was something
really bad where like
man and i ended up
yeah kind of didn't know what had
happened and i ended up back in my hotel
room like a couple days later and i
remember i woke up from a night of just
sweating the fever had finally broke and
i was now on antibiotics or whatever it
was and i woke up and i
i look i'm squinting and i look in the
corner of my
room and i see this the biggest basket i
have ever seen in my life like it was
it was like the size of a car like a
smart car and it was just like snacks
and things and whatever and i'm like who
the [ __ ] do i know in la i don't know
anyone in l.a like how could somebody's
giving me you know where this is going
right and so i sort of walk up to the
thing it's got the little card and i
open the card and it says
welcome to a great mission love tom and
jj
and that's when it really hit me that i
had gotten the movie because i didn't
really remember that yeah you must have
been delirious when you got casual i was
delirious i was delirious but i mean
that i was genuinely delirious i didn't
know what was happening
you must have thought like it'd be funny
if like
now that you jj what he responded to was
like how feverish you were and you were
sweating maybe he thought you were like
in the scene
and he probably said he's a much better
actor than i actually yeah yeah he's
like when you start shooting it he's
like what's happening where's all the
sweat and her hands shaking and
what happened to all that
she was so much remember that just when
you were good
yeah yeah it was funny but you know what
was you know you know what was weird is
before i walked in i'll never forget
april said to me she said
it's 10 minutes maggie you're gonna read
three scenes and i was like oh okay like
i i was so sick and she said look at me
if you get through this
you will change your life in ten minutes
no problem and i was like
oh my god and so i went to the room and
i remember
feeling that way and the minute he said
action i just
there was nothing sick about me
right well you know nothing
it's adrenaline
it's that it's you know people talk
about having superhuman moments and
that was your moment where you needed to
lift a car off of somebody i mean like
that's pretty much yeah i'm a little
disappointed jj wasn't like your mission
should you choose to accept it like you
didn't work that into
saying that you got the party no he did
he was tired
he had a fever too yeah
well and and he was trying to get people
cat well tom was promoting war of the
worlds at the time so he was all around
the world
he just started dating katie so it was
like a big
hoo-ha
ps i was living overseas for seven years
i didn't know who katie was and i didn't
know what that meant and i had to have
carrie russell explain to me what was
happening
okay
you didn't have dawson's creek in hong
kong
i didn't have dawson's creed in hong
kong and i didn't see the oprah episode
and like i didn't know any of them so
karen's like wait a minute you don't
know and she was like did you see
dawson's craig i'm like no and then
she's like oh katie she's an actress i'm
like i don't know that she's like tell
me yourself
right exactly
i'm a big fellow city fan but i never
saw a dog
so
you know so she took me to lunch one day
i was like maggie like let me just tell
you what's happening here and i was like
oh my god greatest and we're still
friends like carrie russell is one of
the coolest like i landed on this big
movie with two
of the coolest actresses on the planet
carrie russell and michelle monahan and
it was like
i mean to enter on that level with girl
girls girls who are that cool and that
inclusive and that amazing
was it's all downhill from there really
and then you work on die hard and um
that was shortly die-hard with bruce and
this other girl i forget where her name
was justin oh justin justice yeah you've
uh
but those girls also must have been as
everyone on die hard was so impressed by
your like natural martial arts
that must give you a lot of confidence
to have those martial arts skills does
it
well my thing is that like
physicality like there's no question
like i'm not
those mma girls so i i mean yeah sure
they could probably beat up any guy they
meet like i'm definitely not that person
but
i understand like the male physicality
versus the female physicality under most
circumstances is not comparable
obviously i imagine you could beat me up
like how how many people for sure but i
mean what i'm saying is like if it's in
us
what about togo what about we have a
mutual friend john togo could you beat
him
you know toga's pretty thick
he's thick yeah he's pretty big he's
sick he seems like he'll be really
strong i mean don't don't but if he's
strong i feel like well he listens to
the show
if a strong person like a strong man
came at you though in an alley do you
feel confident that you could defend
yourself not necessarily beat them up
but like right defend and deflect as as
as probably better than a lot of people
i would say yes i would say that's true
but the other thing with women not that
this is like a free women's self-defense
class but i had this incident last year
where i was walking i was in santa
monica which as you know anime santa
monica but shout out to shady as hell
like people don't understand like
there's a lot of weirdness that goes on
in this very rich area
so i was walking
to from the farmer's market to um
to my car which was parked in one of
those side alleys because i'm me i had
noticed that there was a guy in a hoodie
following me for two blocks
and i was aware that he crossed the
street and i was aware that he's now
behind me and i was aware that it had
been a few blocks and i was also aware
that i was walking further away from the
farmers market so there's no one else
parked in these side alleys because it's
all towaways right but i had a special
permit for my friend's business so i'm
like okay so this guy's it's been two
blocks and he crossed the street now
he's behind me and now i'm okay now i'm
gonna take a right and i'm walking
further down the alley he just took a
right now he's still behind me okay so i
moved to the left and i was definitely
scared i mean he was a big guy he was
like six two and the whole thing and he
had his hood up and his face was covered
on purpose
my car was parked to the left so i start
to move over to the left which doesn't
give him any room to he's gotta be
walking on the right
and i immediately you know put my
open my trunk and i'm putting all my
fruits and vegetables down and he's sort
of parallel to me now like almost
parallel to me and
i'm i'm watching him and he
walks sort of past me by about a foot
and he starts to slow down a little
and so i'm like okay and i'm not
physically more powerful than this
person i i can see in his physicality
that he would overpower him
i put my groceries down i said no i'm
not going to be bullied and i'm not
going to be made to feel afraid
so i just started screaming and i said
you know i just started swearing at him
and i said oh now you're slowing down i
said what you think you scare me
following me you [ __ ] and i'm
screaming from the top of my lungs i'm
like you think you scare me you don't
[ __ ] scare me get the keep [ __ ]
walking you stupid i mean i'm screaming
my head and you out this is the last
thing an assailant wants you know
and so i'm small but i'm mighty in my
spirit and so i'm gonna scream and
defend myself before you ever touch me
and he ran wow no [ __ ] well first of all
i'm drawing attention like anything it's
so funny if he was like just a fan of
yours if he was like i just wanted an
autograph
with my hood up and my hands in my
pockets he has a big nikita poster
yeah he rolls it out he rolls it get the
[ __ ] out of here
she's so much friendlier on tv
life could be a dream sweetheart
[Music]
i'm gonna put you on the spot because
this is something you can't do with an
animal and
one of my favorite stories of yours is
when you were pursued
by
coyotes i had to use my bike to defend
myself and my pitbull
so that this coyote didn't eat her that
was scuba that was scuba yeah that was
the crumbs wow yeah the cool yeah
and you remember coops was a strong dog
and she's oh yeah
she was aggressive she was aggressive
people she was she was abused and i took
her in
and to see a pit bull afraid i was like
oh my god that coyote is going to kill
her in front of me so what happened so
you were invented you were in the valley
right and you were like you were walking
scuba and you just noticed this coyote
was it one coyote following what just
one but there's never one right you see
one but there's more and so and as we
got closer to it i was riding my bike my
dog was running i went
okay well we're just gonna keep going
and we passed it but we were going up a
hill and it was a dead end so the only
way home was
down that hill
past that same coyote who on my way up
the hill started to trot after us
as we rode down the hill i looked at my
dog and i just said scuba we're just
gonna you and i are gonna book it we're
i'm gonna pedal so fast and you're gonna
run and we're just gonna run all the way
home okay
and she was like you could just see the
fear she knew she was being hunted and
so
we take off down the hill and the coyote
has actually waited behind a bush
and then as we're speeding down the hill
it takes off parallel to us and is
running at the same speed as my bike my
god oh no i have never been so scared in
my life and i broke too hard i fell off
my bike
my dog's leash i it was the biggest
disaster and then as it's running
towards it it was b b lined to my dog i
picked up my bike and i used the entire
bicycle and i was slamming it on the
ground and screaming to try and deter it
on some level and it did a little bit
but i was but i could tell he was just
really trying to make a circle around me
it was as if i wasn't even there
oh my god it acted like i didn't exist
scuba was terrified she was hiding
behind me and i'm screaming and i'm so
scared and i'm crying now i'm crying
and i see this jogger in the distance
and i'm like please help me my dog's
gonna die like i'm crying and screaming
and he's like oh my god
he's got the hoodie yeah same guy he's
like
another guy different guy
yeah
so he was just a morning jogger and he
came and picked up a bunch of rocks and
was throwing them at the coyote and he
was like run
keep running and i'll keep throwing
rocks just keep running holy [ __ ] and
that's how i got home
wow and so it's you you've played all
these
badass women and so many things mission
impossible die hard then the divergent
series nikita do you ever want to play
someone who isn't a badass
yes yes i am uh interested in that and
um i i just i'd have a comedy coming out
this year actually which is gonna be
really fun but what's the what is it
it's called the argument and um do you
know jason schwartzman
yeah i love schwartzman so schwartzman's
brother do you know i haven't worked
with him
i do know robert yes robert's great
robert directed his tiny movie we shot
at his house
oh my god for like a hundred thousand
dollars or something and it was supposed
to uh premiere at tribeca and then
obviously try to get canceled so
but i guess the office still stands and
i know why
so we'll be premiering at tribeca
whenever it comes back oh that's great
wait was is jason in it
jason is he was gonna be in it he's not
it's me and dan fogler
oh oh your old buddy okay my little
buddy
your balls are fury
casper yeah oh cool oh that's a good
cast uh i'm glad i'm glad you're doing a
comedy because you
are funny and nobody knows no one knows
that
um no one's ever because you've never
been funny to anyone well no no it's not
a lie that's not what people think of
you as but yeah
very funny um
we laughed
so much
hard
well what was that well so i remember
the first week that we worked together
was that it was all that stuff in the
factory or something it's when you hold
us hostage and then you get into the big
fight for this is die hard four oh in
redondo
life or die hard yeah live free or die
hard we were way out in the in yeah
we're shooting nights you're there in
these conditions and i had been working
on it for at that point like i don't
know a month at least a month i think
and um and so i i kind of understood
the need for patients and these
different rhythms that had been
established uh
and so but you're just coming in and you
were such a breath of fresh air it was
so
[ __ ] fun and even when we were
waiting around and people are getting
frustrated and
oh we were laughing so much we it was so
much funny it was so ridiculous
god for you um oh thank god for you yeah
we were kind of bookended it was
interesting it was just interesting you
guys know
oh who is that dogs that's um romeo and
nevaeh
oh yeah romeo i haven't i haven't met
nevaeh well max you only have two dogs
now
i only have two dogs but
i just sent you a photo before we got on
the podcast
oh oh did you see the photo i sent you
no let me see
[Music]
you said we need to talk about that
that's what you said in the text
oh oh yeah i did see that of course oh
okay yeah the photo yeah oh my that's
your new dog
well i think so i think oh boy okay
okay so this is important i run can i
run two names by you
yes because i need advice hold on i have
to let people know because this is not a
visual medium uh i am look so maggie
sent me a photo of
one of i've seen a lot of i've seen a
lot of cute puppies in my time
uh but this thing is
ridiculous it's this little like kind of
a wiry-haired it's got a dark nose the
rest of it is beige it's different
mottled colors it is so [ __ ] cute no
you know what it looks like it looks
like a tiny little german shepherd
wiry terrier
yeah wiry
god i wish i could show people it's one
of
those
tiny german shepherds that's what it
looks like yes yeah but its ears are
pointed down it's got this incredibly
innoc it's like whatever it's a pup it's
a really kind of has a faux hawk you see
his little mohawk
it looks like it's been um
it needs to be cleaned maybe but in a
cute way you know it's got that it's the
wiry hair
it's it looks like a little raga muffin
it's so cute first i want to give some
context
maggie has been rescuing dogs for i mean
since you were my whole life in hong
kong my entire your whole life um
and when maggie and i met that week on
yeah on die hard you had at the time
seven dogs i think yeah seven or eight
all of them were big ish pretty much
with the exception of like
two two of them
uh i thought just one mr p right
no and then i acquired a little terrier
from the detroit
detroit michigan shelter city shelter
called chewie
oh yeah
chewbacca yeah chewbacca
but at one point the best was when i did
i didn't know chewie well but
mr p was a little chihuahua and he was
the alpha of the group this is the best
part and he was three pounds
yeah he was the tiniest little
and he would he ruled the roost he was
like such an officious he was so like
[ __ ] to the other dogs
and they all listened to him they all
like put up with it and he'd be like no
and and these big dogs like wiley uh uh
these huge german shepherds and pitbulls
they would all fall on german shepherds
yeah yeah i'll fall in line like sorry
sorry sir he was like no now you listen
to me
here's how it's going down
that's how i heard mr p in my head
no but you know do you ever do you ever
remember the first time you because you
thought he was so cute like everyone
else and you were like hey max where
where's mr p and i said he's in my
trailer we're on die hard wearing the
hair and makeup trailer getting done in
the morning
and you said hey max um since you're
still in here and makeup can i do you
mind if i go to your trailer just go see
him and i said yeah um oh good luck yeah
and you were like why did you pause
and i said yeah because you were
just
go in with confidence
and you have a flat what is that i'm not
capable of that
well i told you to do that and then i
continued in the process getting my
makeup done and half an hour had gone by
like i didn't know where you i was like
where's justin so i thought you were
coming back and so i go to look for you
and i i'll never forget the scene i
opened the door to my trailer and i i
honestly thought i was gonna die
laughing that morning
and it's it's it's my my couch whatever
couch it was in the trailer and it was a
bit of a life was a bit longer than most
couches and on one end you were sitting
all the way jammed into the corner and
then on the other end all the way to the
right was pedro and you were facing each
other and he was going ah
[Laughter]
[Applause]
yeah i didn't make any headway
so much for the confidence
you knew exactly what you were dealing
with
you're like oh i can break this guy
uh
yeah
yeah yeah i never although in my defense
i yeah mr p
you underplayed i think
how aggressive mr p could be you know
and then that was an [ __ ] move by me
because no no it's just in your nature
it's like because you
don't want to alarm you don't want to
fill someone some a fear-based person
like me with more fear who was the one
it was a german shepherd it wasn't wiley
um caesar caesar was like a
very
there was something in his like a spirit
of some special
creature in him yeah he was the love of
my life
yeah i only lost him like i mean it's
gonna be two years in september
yeah but he
is still with me all the time
we're so connected like we're just so i
don't know if i ever told you that you
know
the last week of his life which i kind
of knew was the last week i decided
uh i've signed a few things but i i was
so distraught that he was getting weaker
that i would wasn't really noticing the
signs and the support that he had to
cross over soon
and i'm in my yard and i'm like talking
to my friend on the phone and this white
this hawk swooped like over my head
so close that i look up and i'm like
what i've never seen a hawk that looks
like this i've never seen a hawk that
look since that looks like this
it was mostly white which they don't
have in
um it landed in this enormous tree that
overlooked the house and that bird
showed up
about a week before he died and then it
left after he died and it i never saw it
again yeah like i said i've witnessed
like oh spiritual moments between you
and animals and for anyone listening
who's like okay that's nonsense i
probably would have thought that before
i met you before i knew somebody that
was so in tuned with
i've never known anyone to be so uh in
tune with topics with other creatures
they're like i feel like you're their
protector i think caesar
knew what you did for him uh how you
saved his life and and and the lengths
to which you went to do that and i think
that that's i think that bonded you guys
in a way that i'm telling you like i i i
wonder if i'll ever in my lifetime see
that kind of
connection between an animal and well
what's funny is that when i when i had
to put him down justin
the doctor who came over
you know i sang to him and he died in my
arms and
she took him away and then she wrote me
a card like a week later you know always
like thank you for your business or
whatever
drew me a card sent me a card and wrote
this letter in it or she said to me
because the doctor was crying which i
thought was interesting because i'd not
seen that you know with a doctor putting
the dog down
and oh yeah she wrote me this letter
sensitized
right exactly and she said
i
have to apologize for like the amount of
emotion that came out of me during my
visit with you and and your beautiful
boy but she said
i could not contain my emotion because i
had never seen
a love like that
yeah it was so
it moved me
deeply
to watch you transition him out of this
the physical body into the vibrational
body and the trust
that existed between the two of you and
the love was so it was deeply moving to
me and i
didn't know how to control it
didn't you have an interaction with
caesar milan and caesar milan was like
am i making this up where he was like
uh you kind of know what you're doing
he he did but he also told me that i
gave caesar my dog caesar
too much power because when i adopted
him i was single and i gave him the
boyfriend position
and i never
and i never made him
um give up his his you know
his status
oh interesting so what was that like
when you had other when you had human
boyfriends
any time there was like a disagreement
or an argument with a human boyfriend
um he would get up very slowly like a
cat he moved like a cat he was like a
jungle cat yeah he did he was graceful
yeah he was graceful and and very sleek
and so he would get up very slowly from
the sofa and he'd walk over and he'd
stand
in between the two of us and he'd look
whoever the gentleman was dead in his
eye meet his back to me
and calmly just stand there
i understand there's a disagreement
going on right now
but if anything gets more heightened
than my liking
i'm going to go after you dude
so just so you know i'm here oh my god
like look at such a great but then on
the flip side i had the doctaio remember
teo yeah okay this dog tayo who was like
a real healing dog it's a
teo if i was in an argument with anyone
teo would whoever was losing the
argument is not necessarily who was
right
but whoever was losing in the argument
he would go to and comfort
oh he was so like empathetic like so
empathetic just so sensitive and kind of
red when there was a void yeah teo was
he was my gay dog
yeah
yeah tayo was he was painfully good
looking
beautiful yeah it was a rough very very
light beige yeah with the pink nose yes
yes yeah yeah yeah oh i love his tail
yeah
he was my gay son
i want to mention your what you're doing
now you have maggie has a company called
keep up
i'll let you talk about a little bit
about it because it's fascinating how it
came to be and
how sustainable it is um what exactly
what motivated that it's a clothing
company but maybe talk a little bit
about how that came to be
you know about 10 years ago i was
really fascinated by all the the new
technology that was happening in the
sustainable space as far as like yarns
and fabrics went and i was sort of i
don't know there was something about it
that was that was really i knew that
fashion was very wasteful a particularly
uh fast fashion
and um i was i was trying to research
ways
to to make things better you know to
make them work better for us
i
the fabrics at the time the yarn that
was coming out was not it just wasn't up
to par yet and then a couple years ago i
started to look more into it as
technology started to get better
and
i realized that we were getting to a
point where we could make polyester
that from recycled materials that was
almost virgin
almost undetectably virgin
and that
i know and that we were producing
different different sources you can make
you can recycle fishing nets but all
plastic
uh so different different just sort of
um
uh really it's really trash i mean
you're you're reusing trash and you're
you're collecting it and they're melting
it down and
turning it into flakes and those flakes
are then spun into uh yarn god
that is so cool
yeah these are like so everyone's seen
the pictures of the floating the masses
of plastic floating in the ocean and and
they hear the statistics about how much
uh plastic remains in the ocean so
this is a way to actually
do something about this is like a very
practical
way to combat that yeah yeah
well we we say uh that we're turning
waste into one right so things that
would just end up in a landfill things
that would end up in the ocean things
that would things that are disposable
because we live in such a disposable
culture now you know i mean sure single
use all this stuff
um
we decided at the time when by the way
plastic isn't a it's it's a really
incredible invention but what happened
was
because they were going to make so much
money off the invention of plastic there
was no regulation around it right so
there was no
bird's-eye view there was no bigger
thinking about okay well we're going to
produce all of this but what are we
going to do with it once it exists right
it's going to pile up and there's going
to be nowhere for it to go i've been an
ocean activist for you know 15 years and
for me
i i didn't i don't want to start a
company that was
that just
made another commodity that was going to
be thrown away i wanted it to have
purpose and i wanted it to have
education behind it and i wanted to
really
really truly put that put the recycling
um
uh recycled
create a recycled fabric
that was so uniquely marketed
yeah practical but that was so unique to
the market that hadn't been done yet
um and there were companies that i
really loved like patagonia and
different companies who have always
welcomed different surf companies have
always used recycled uh an element of
recycled
um yarn in their in their clothing
but i hadn't seen anyone who'd ever done
100 recycled blend like really figured
out what that blend was and that they
could bring a garment to market that was
a hundred percent uh recycled and so
that's what i set out to do and so i
went to find all these
textile manufacturers and said hey does
this exist and they're like no and if
you want to if you want to create that
you're going to have to spend the money
for r d and make it happen because it
doesn't exist right now
so that's what i did wow
so so
when somebody says that to you somebody
who
is in the business and and is in that
space occupies like a knowledgeable
position in that space
how do you then hear that
and
and then go out and and create it and
find it
i'm kind of one of those people where if
you tell me that i can't do it i'm going
to yeah and i'm not going to do it
because i need to prove you wrong i'm
doing it because i i believe that i
can't okay what is your most commonly
used emoji
oh the laughing uh always the laughing
oh yeah yeah you mean the laugh crying
the laugh crying yeah the laugh crying
okay it's funny it's it's hard to pivot
from something so like significant and
special that you're doing like saving
the world and getting rid of ocean
plastic to so what's your most commonly
used emoji but you know listen i would i
would put them on par
yeah okay all right um not the recycle
emoji weird
uh okay yeah laughing emoji is a good
one do you write out do you just you say
that when you find something funny do
you do lol do you do hahaha
you know what's funny is i do hahaha on
my microphone which is the dorkiest and
worst way to do hahaha because it does a
space in between each ha
oh really
pretty much yeah so it's it's i don't
know what people are thinking when they
get that from me but oh that's funny
i'll be looking that's fine i was like
oh i never get that from you that must
mean you never laugh at the text
um i get a lot of question marks and
that quizzical emoji the guy who's like
you guys scratch your shin
if you could have one snack food for the
rest of your life what would it be
potato chips are just so great oh
okay salt vinegar
salt and vinegar yeah okay great uh
favorite movie of all time but you know
my favorite movie for a very long time
was a movie called betty blue it's a
french film the story is about a woman
who's essentially who's mentally ill
and
but she's in and she's in love with this
man and it's their love story and like
in the end like he she's so destructive
like he can't save her like there's no
like he loves her so much but alert
it's just it's it's really
it's it's like a painful painfully
beautiful
love story and not everyone you love you
can save you know what i mean
they all
if you had to live somewhere else where
would it be
somewhere else like fantasy wise or
somewhere practical
no no like well both like practical for
your life that would
be oh you know i guess well i also i
also want to live in costa rica
oh yeah yeah yeah oh my god
i have actual plans to live there too
if you could have dinner with three
people dead or alive whom you've never
met who would they be
i think that jesus would be one of them
who doesn't want to have dinner with
jesus
yeah yeah i know i know
every
i mean all the prophets
who's your favorite muppet
oh
i mean there's no kermit
kermit okay yeah
yeah i mean i like the scientist and
beaker too but i also like the one who
plays the heart the girl who plays the
harp
uh a girl who plays you mean jan
you like the one who's like that james
he's always like yeah man oh yeah yeah
oh she you know she played the harp
yeah we were just talking about some of
those
oh her name's janice
yeah jen is er because it's everything
she's like a little out of it she's kind
of fried yeah she's always like a little
out of it
yeah
oh i love you you have a little janice
in you sometimes i do um i love james uh
if you could have uh one superpower what
would it be uh invisibility
yeah
that's it that's hard to get yeah
um what would you do with it what's the
first stop you would make where would
you go
oh i would go to like um i'm i have like
all these vigilante dreams of like being
a writer
so i have all these dreams like sneaking
into like
like people who traffic children and
experiment on animals like i just had
these dreams of me going in like
invisible and then once in there
creating havoc and releasing all these
defenseless lives and i mean this is a
dream
if you could be reincarnated as a
non-human animal uh what would it be
a non-human animal oh you know i would
probably like
to see the depths of the oceans to be
honest so oh yeah
maybe one of the great whales you know
maybe one of them
one of the you know i don't know like uh
maybe a humpback or a fin whale or or or
an orca i don't know one of the uh i
don't know i remember that picture you
sent me uh when you swam with the whale
shark
oh that's one of the coolest damages i
didn't think was you
oh it's like a screensaver it's like a
mask i know
yeah yeah
in fact i still wonder if it's you
yeah i was gonna say it's good life well
yeah it's really good words if anyone's
gonna pull off that lie it's you okay uh
would you rather be called um would you
rather be called unattractive or unfunny
oh unfunny would be horrifying
yeah that'd be rough
if you know if people were like yeah
she's nice but she's just like she tried
to be funny and she's not oh oh god oh
the nightmare that'd be so sad
which golden girl do you most identify
with
dorothy blanche rose or sophia
well
i you know
the who's the funnest blanche blanche
yeah she is she's the good time charlie
oh you know what i want
my dream funny that you brought up the
golden girls is my dream is to have four
donkeys and name them after the golden
girls
why don't you peaches yes because i'm
obsessed with donkeys oh really oh you
sh
oh do you have like an unhealthy
really i didn't know
i think i know these answers but dogs
versus cats uh dogs but but i'm an
animal person so i don't want to exclude
anyone
um beetles rolling stones beetles or
rolling stones oh
that you can't do that too okay sorry
sorry sorry um but but if i had to pick
one it's the beatles i mean come on yeah
yeah yeah okay good that was the right
answer yeah okay all right um how uh i'm
i know how i
am going to remember you not that i'm
gonna die first um i didn't mean to
suggest that i mean that yeah you're
gonna die first um i think you're gonna
live to be like 120 but um
how how do you want people to
remember you how do you want to be
thought of i suppose i think i just want
people to know that i did the best that
i could for everyone and everything that
i cared about well that is such an
understatement but um it does and you
i think more than have you are
i've always just so admired you and love
you and uh i'm so glad we got to do this
i love you more
um and thank you for letting me blab on
and on about the things that i care
about because it means a lot to me
thanks for giving me a plan we're not
rolling we should we should start
recording sorry i've made that joke
every time
it's so stupid uh of course i've been
looking forward to this this was fun all
right i love you i i'll talk to you soon
love you bye guys thank you so much
okay bye
[Music]
so
so that happened
what was yours like why did you do it
like that
my i'll tell you how you made my
experience about the interview how was
it like
no that that was you know that was was
um
just real gratitude that i got to have
that with her because we're in
quarantine now and it's just nice on a
very personal selfish level where was
she she was in la she could you hear you
could hear like birds and stuff in the
back yeah she was out on her birds are
in new york i know she lives part time
in new york too that's a good point yeah
she has a place she's a place in
westchester i went to see her in
westchester recently and she um she was
like we gotta we're gonna have dinner
with uh my friend
and we went to pick up her friend
liesel who was
almost 90 i think she was maybe 91
uh and lisa was the first
maggie has the most impressive friend
she wasn't one of the von trapp children
no but she sounds like she was uh no she
was i think i made that joke and uh
maggie's a great laugher isn't she
she is which helps explain your
connection i think i know i know
selfishly you love a good audience i do
i do i needy needy please find me funny
um but lisa was uh it was known
it made me laugh because maggie just has
such impressive friends and she was the
first uh female
photojournalist at life magazine or
maybe editor of yeah and she had the
most fascinating stories about
photographing juan peron
is did i mispronounce that juan peron
juan perez
yeah eva peron's husband and um and
fidel castro and was like
chummy with them uh and walt disney
she had said walt disney was um more
basically more of a dick than uh she's
like fidel and wants these these people
that we think of as being uh dictators
were actually quite charming
to her and she really put the dick in
dictator yeah that was good
as you pull on your mustache gross wow
you have a dictator mustache i do
you
excited about that kind of because
dictators tend to have really full
length
it is full like a saddam hussein yeah
that's true stalin has stalin yeah
hussein stalin is like mustache goals
yeah you know one of the most evil men
who's ever lived probably but you know
great mustang the grade mustang you know
who had a you know what dictator the
gross mustache uh was let me think uh oh
pol pot
yeah did he even try to have a mustache
yeah he did yeah so did um
[Laughter]
i bet she's never gotten that before
oh gaddafi
muammar gaddafi yeah i'm trying to
picture his mustache oh gross fish all
right so did um ho chi minh didn't have
great uh
well anyway let's get back to maggie uh
no mustache on maggie she just is a very
impressive human being i've always
thought that yeah i've known her for a
good
uh decade plus now yeah she's been over
for family meals uh she's our family
loves you yeah we've spent a lot of time
with her and she is
um remains
impressive yeah and
uh kind and intelligent
articulate uh there when she was talking
about and i know and i i had known about
her period of struggle and her life and
when she was starting on her career how
she was broke i had heard her tell a
version of that story before but
it remains
so hard to picture because when i think
of her
i think of someone who is
so incredibly
put together and successful
and almost regal she has a kind of regal
yeah um poised like it's poor like like
a princess
she's like a princess to me
not like a spoiled she's gonna not in
the way that she's like spoiled and like
full of herself she's gonna make fun of
you for this but it's true she has kind
of a regal air about her yeah there's a
sense of pride that she has even in the
way she stands she has such impressive
um stretches posture yeah but you know
and i don't this is not my story to tell
and she and we didn't get too deep into
it but she
did
suffer a lot of abuse at the hands of
men and i had she alluded to that i
don't think i'm speaking out of turn uh
but what she doesn't have is any
bitterness or
animosity you know she is very good at
letting go and if not letting go
channeling a lot of her experiences into
positive
things positive pursuits she mentioned
that she um people often ask her
whether she likes animals more than
humans yeah
and she claimed that she doesn't that
she she loves animals she loves humans
and you know she
doesn't pick one side or the other but
it certainly seems like she prefers
animals and i was wondering not to
psychoanalyze her but uh how much that
might have to do with this abuse you're
talking about and also
from her experience in the modeling
industry that sounds really cruel and
abusive yeah um so i think she's had
experiences with humans that are less
than
good yeah and and
so when she sees animals as being like
as she says completely judgment free
it makes sense to me that she would
prefer them but i wouldn't describe her
as an animal person the way i would
describe you as an animal person she has
something above and beyond what anyone
else has that i've whom i've met and she
has like a real kinship with animals
yeah and she's like ace ventura
yes or doctor doolittle except she
doesn't talk
such
conviction i mean everything she
promotes
all the activism she does comes from a
place of such
deep true conviction principles of
extremely principles yes and
and i think we have both seen examples
of people who uh are
activists more for their own good than
something else um
um you've been using the word lovely a
lot i have i know i noticed that yes i
noticed it oh my god that's fine i
noticed in the leslie jordan interview i
think pretty much maybe that's where it
started oh maybe yeah you're gonna blame
leslie jordan no i don't really mind it
i also referred to somebody else as
being lovely oh did i say all right you
said it in this i did i did you referred
to a couple times jay leno is lovely i
did no i did
hey yeah you guess i am loving things
lovely he i know weird well maybe
because maggie uses it i also am uh i'm
prone to
being very influenced this is probably
not a good thing something i should brag
about to being influenced by the person
i'm i'm talking to especially if it's
something i really like admire like
maggie right or someone who has a very
um
distinguishable
cadence or something like
sam
roberts when i'm around it's very hard
to not talk like him when you're around
i know i'll start saying oh my god yeah
yeah but not just you i i've noticed
with him specifically everyone starts to
sound like him when they spend time with
him she did an impression of her mom
who's vietnamese and
you
did like a half-hearted impression of
her after that and i you but you didn't
really commit to it because you can't
yeah i know and maggie does a really
good impression but i
can't we always talk about that maggie
also teases me a lot about looking a
little asian
and and whenever i do something that
good or bad that had that
she deems to be
more popular in the asian community she
kind of points it out right it's just
it's just fun you also revere the asian
community i
yeah i i think i've told this story
before but i was talking to a girl at a
bar once and she said so what percentage
asian are you and
around that time for whatever reason
people were mistaking me for being part
asian and i said oh i'm not i'm zero
percent she was not come on seriously
what is like 50 asian and i said no none
uh and she got really offended she said
look i have a friend who's mixed like
you and he always denies his asian
heritage and she stormed away and i said
to her as i would she sounds a little
unhappy yeah i think so well are you
saying that because she's asian uh you
didn't say that she was there she i
didn't no that's a key part of the story
friend who is just mixed race really
butchering stories lately so she was
asian she was asian and she said maybe
you did say it i didn't hear it no i
don't think you said it then but i the
point is i um
i occasionally get
and i i would be flattered i'm flattered
i would love to be in fact when we did
that there was a sponsor who was kind of
like a 23andme uh sponsor and
ancestry.com.com right uh it was a while
ago it was one of our first one they
never
re-upped
no but how many times can you take your
uh get your genetics tested that's true
no but whatever so when i did that i was
praying that there would be some asian i
thought it'd be cool to have a little of
course asian uh in me maggie there's
nobody better to travel with in
in asia in tokyo except wouldn't it be
isn't it sort of annoying that she's so
famous there that you can't go anywhere
without people like making a scene yeah
she really is you've been to chinatown
with her right you've been
no well you certainly have been to
chinese to asian restaurants with me
when i mention her i like to name drop
her you always too yeah and they're
always like uh yeah i know maggie yeah
they're like oh duh it's like asking if
you know tom cruise yeah i know it's
insulting yeah yeah and she that's
another thing i really love about her is
she
i mean you would never know that she has
that level of fame in like a huge part
of the world it's not like she's famous
in reykjavik iceland yeah it's a massive
continent
asia is a very large place and she
remains one of the most
famous people there and she's just such
a i mean you know her so she was uh you
guys were talking about
um
the physicality between difference
between men and women and how
even though she is
a martial artist and she is tough and
badass
there are still limitations to that so
that so if she were to encounter like a
yeah a big strong man yeah
she wouldn't be able to physically
compete with them just because of the
nature of the size difference and the
muscle difference
uh and you got like a little surge of
confidence and you're like oh so do you
think like
you could
like i you could be yeah
i could and she was like oh you oh for
sure but
she's like i was talking more about like
you know a man like a man yeah with some
muscle oh man there was i i can't really
tell the full story unfortunately which
i know is a tease but there was a day
there was a moment on her first one of
her first days on die hard where she was
doing a fight scene with bruce and
he was hesitating to do this particular
move because
he just thought it was unrealistic that
maggie would be able to grab his fist
and do this move where she basically
twisted his arm behind his back and
the stunt guy then the director len
finally they just said well
what maggie why don't why don't you just
do it you know
bruce was like come on there's no way
like no offense no offense but come on
and and in bruce's defense like he he's
a pretty big guy it's um and maggie is
quite small she's like thin
and so she they did it kind of full
speed ahead they like did bruce went to
punch her in the face and maggie like
[ __ ] lightning it was one of the
coolest things i've ever seen in my life
she her hand shot up
grabbed his fist with her palm and it
twisted his arm behind his back and it
all happened so fast and it disarmed
bruce and he was like okay okay okay you
know i can't i remember you telling me
that story years ago so i was under the
impression that she could
um submit anything i think she was
actually the guy you know that she comes
across in a dark alley i think she was
actually well two things she may have
been being i think she was being modest
i think she could have i don't know if
she could have taken that guy bruce
actually isn't he's sort of my height
he's not that no he's not that tall and
you know he was a little bit older when
we did that and you know the encounter
she had with that guy in the hoodie he
was she said she was like six foot two
and that's probably a little different
but
uh yeah she i wonder if she's
more of a badass than she even gives
herself credit for
yeah um
she
talked about having vigilante dreams do
you remember that she was yes just
dreams about like yeah savings saving
and like sneaking into buildings
together yeah and i realized that i've i
mostly have dreams about like missing
flights yeah and anxiety and anxiety
like being uh having an exam in college
that i'm not prepared for or something
and i think what you dream about really
uh says a lot of it says a lot about you
yeah oh i wonder if what it says about
me my dreams lately i've been having
dreams about like not watering my plants
and
you know
um i've i've been having dreams about
missing people too and i guess
quarantine dreams
uh anyway did i ever tell you when i
went to a um see she used to she was a
big supporter of this animal rights
organization called sea shepherd and we
went to a fundraiser together
and i bid on this guitar signed by all
four beatles oh that was with her i
remember the guitar and i it was kind of
like going once going twice and i was
like oh i thought people there were a
lot of like
fancy people
high rollers in there i got it i like
bid high and i got it and it turns and i
was like well it's going to a good cause
c shepherd and i regret it or anything
but years later i found out that
i think i had a crazy it was fake
if you like saw the signatures it's like
jim bob todd and steve
who's that
she's the best she's the best
and she's such a supporter of the show
she's really she is yeah she loves the
show let's read a letter okay all right
you go on and on
okay here's a letter andy l
subject boyfriend twins
dear justin and christian long time
listener thanks andy first time writer
at the end of your interview with
morocco your breakdown discussion
broached the subject of gay men
seemingly being attracted to other men
that are just like them yes this that
might have been offensive uh as a gay
man myself i can attest this is true
all right oh what a great you just got
cleared
okay though it's not an across-the-board
phenomenon it is prevalent enough that
it has been given its own term
boyfriend twins oh i didn't know that
this typically refers to gay men in
relationships where they physically
resemble one another did you know that
to the point of being an uncanny
resemblance i like that boyfriend twins
but if you ask me this can also extend
to men who have very similar tastes
social dispositions and upbringing
whether or not they look the same
i don't understand this myself i've
always felt that there is value in the
unknown and the true adventure of a
romantic relationship is discovering new
things
with a new person and giving them the
same in return that's how we grow and
become better as a whole well said andy
anyhow to end this rant christian might
have the right of it
you would make a good catch for any gay
man
thanks andy i feel like i said that
wrong for any gay man
okay man i said
what's the difference i don't know how
would you say that anything you'd make a
great
it should be for any gay man right i
don't know how he was saying it i wonder
for any gay man yeah for any gay man
because it wouldn't make sense if you
wouldn't be a catcher for any man
it's right so regardless the emphasis
wouldn't be on the gay it's just a what
a flattering thing to say personally any
gay man you also wouldn't be catching
for a gay woman so you're right it would
be any gay man although you'd be a catch
for any gay man i bet especially the way
i look now there may be some gay women
who find me attractive why do you say
that how do you look now a little kd
language you do yeah yeah you have katie
lane vibes yeah
back to the andy's letter
very flattering letter personally i
think we'd get along well but i'd
probably have to have you keep your
frogs to yourself i can just picture
andy like talking about me with our
other friends or our gay couple friends
and like oh he's always yeah
yeah justin and his frogs
yeah uh they so back to andy they freak
me out and i'll freak you out freak me
out and i won't have them near me it's
probably a phobia wow wow
i understand why i don't know if things
will work out between you no
i'm so into frogs i'm catching them all
the time god you sound like jerry
i'm glad to hear you're both well after
your brush with kovid uh thank you andy
and please continue to provide your
wonderful program kind regards andy what
a nice letter a gentleman god would i i
would get along with him he sounds and
he flatters me he uh
first and foremost i hope he likes
vietnamese food yeah i bet he's a good
laugher um
anyway that is thanks andy you guys want
to write it boyfriend twins huh if you
guys want that thanks for the info yeah
that's good to know if you guys want to
write in our email address is justin
life is short at wondery.com
just to reiterate we've been having so
much fun reading would you rather's your
would you rather on our quarantine
episodes uh those are always welcome and
uh obviously flattering things like andy
rhode are very welcome and
i like that fact too it's nice to learn
things so thank you andy and thank you
so much maggie maggie quigley yeah just
the best i mean what i know i've said
that like you say that about every guest
i do but you actually have a very
special relationship with her so i think
it applies to yeah uh okay and you're
being phony about everyone else
yeah so the one time i'm being honest
hopefully i wonder if you could hear it
in my voice
uh i love her and her family uh shout
out to all the quiglies i hope they're
listening uh and thank you they should
be listening and thanks to you guys for
listening we will see you soon yes see
you soon
life could be a dream
life could be a dream
life is short is hosted by me justin
long and it's pretty white i go down on
long
and it's produced by you christian law
and her megan monaco senior producer is
michelle miche lans audio engineer is
sergio enriquez executive producers are
marshall
louis andernan
lopez for
laundry have a great week
[Music]
what's the name of the movie
the crazy or mad crazy
crazy man asians
crazy mad asians so where do you get
rich from
oh you know i think it's crazy
rich no they're crazy rich asians well
they're crazy rich asians
why did winnie
chris you don't know i'll ask he's right
here
oh craig he said crazy rich asians
that's what i saw yeah
why did winnie want to see that so badly
because she said everybody see and then
it's supposed to be so wonderful
so i said well okay
i won't wait for the netflix to show
something
what did you think of it do you wish you
had waited well honey i don't hear
everything even though i had my hearing
aid on and i couldn't see
even though there were only four people
in the theater but i thought you could
see their faces
you know
i think they could and so
you know she would fill me in but anyhow
i thought it was pretty good would she
fill you in during the movie
but they showed about half a dozen
previews
before after all the advertisements and
i want a lot of crap they have in the
movies today yeah so and every one of
those
previews showed
ugly stuff
so what the hell wants to go to the
movies today what ugly oh you mean like
movies anymore yeah well
you